Speaker 1: And finally, speaking of the Jan.
six committee, Alex Jones has decided to sue
the Jan. six committee and, of course, AT&T
to stop the release of his phone records
to that committee. Now, his argument?
Little interesting. Let's hear it here.
It says quote in the lawsuit a
declaratory judgment that the
subpoena to Alex Jones and the subpoena to
AT&T serve no valid legislative purposes
and exceed the select committees and
Congress's constitutional authority
in violation of the separation of powers principle
contained in the United States Constitution.
Now, if you had stopped before you
got to the separation of powers,
you actually had, what's not considered to be
a terrible legal argument? The separation of
powers has nothing to do with what you're talking
about, though. So you kind of overstepped there,
but let's get to this right, the constitutional
basis for the House of Representatives,
a committee in the House of Representatives to
carry out these investigations, believe it or not.
Is that included in the Constitution? No, no, it's
not. That's something a lot of people do not know,
but the Constitution does not say specifically
explicitly that the House of Representatives
gets to carry out these investigations.
However, precedent tells us otherwise.
Court cases Supreme Court cases tell us otherwise
because the Supreme Court, for several hundred
years now, has interpreted the Constitution
to basically say that the founders intended
for Congress to have this power because, you know,
all other duties. That's actually what they cite.
So the courts have told us Congress does have
this authority, even if it's not always for a
specific legislative purpose. And for the record,
the history buffs out there, you may already know
this. This goes back to 1795. When Congress
conducted its first investigatory action really
happened all throughout the 18th century or,
excuse me, the 19th century, the 20th century, and
of course, all the way to today and court cases
all along the way reaffirmed Congress's authority
to actually do this. So if you were going by the
strict letter of the law in the U.S. Constitution,
this legal argument is actually not that absurd,
which, you know, a little disappointing. But when
you look at past court precedent, when you look
at the precedent that Congress itself has set,
the powers that they have won in these court
cases, then they absolutely have the authority
to do this, even if it's not for an explicitly
legislative purpose. Now, that may be the only
thing because that's still considered a very
legal or a very gray area in the legal world.
That may, may do something to move the needle
a little bit, but I seriously doubt it.
Courts have already ruled, obviously in this
particular matter, not necessarily with Alex
Jones, but in Trump trying to claim executive
privilege from other committees, also saying You
can't have my my financial documents because it's
not for a legislative purpose. Courts have said,
Yeah, we don't care. That doesn't matter.
Doesn't have to be. Again, constitutions,
if you own this, can depend on what kind of judge
it goes up against. But of course, Alex Jones,
if he was in communication with these individuals
inside the White House on the day of the riot,
obviously would be a person of interest,
which would make it a valid subpoena.
If, of course, Congress does have the authority to
even conduct these investigations, which is why,
as I continuously say, the committee needs to
turn their documents and everything they have
over to a special prosecutor and let the
DOJ take it from here. You avoid questions
like this. You avoid some issues. Everybody's a
winner. We got some great content coming up for
you in the bonus show. I'm Farron Cousins,
been sitting in for David Pakman today.
You can find me on Twitter, Facebook, Instagram
at Fair and Balanced Growth podcast dot com.
Unidentified: Thanks for watching,
and I'll see you tomorrow.